quelle classe va venir at il fini au
concours la fièvre est oui
oh
airgas
ouais ça reste un bon son à fond
oui suivi bilal bien sûr ah ouais
c'était une belle prestation journaux me
a été mieux pour bilal je suis d'accord
avec toi avec toi 6e c'est que ça fait
très longtemps qu'on n'avait pas fait
aussi bien
avant c'était patricia kaas qui avait
fait 8e oui voilà tu peux dire sans être
du tout en colère quand elle était
matriarcat sous mais c'est ça ouais
exhortant russie voilà merci en tout cas
je pose une question à mme oui bonsoir
est-ce que c'est dû à so you qui vous a
mené 6e etc été un succès que vous avez
mieux ou dans ce nouveau titre qui ré
germain j'ai mis hou
c'est vrai alors il faut que je
m'explique je mets souvent dans mes
chansons des passages de de guy melodia
qu'au duo c'est mon style oui c'est un
truc qui m'a toujours plu dans chez
d'autres artistes notamment les one
republic qui ont un service de grande
inspiration pour l'écriture du premier
album et ce que je kiffe principalement
aujourd'hui quand je suis souvent sur
scène c'est que c'est très facile à
faire chanter le public parce qu'il faut
pas se rappeler des paroles il faut
simplement chanter en choeur où ça
marche et ça fait plaisir parce qu'il ya
un vrai moment de communion et même
talent heures il y avait des gens qui
connaissaient pas le morceau quand je
les voyais il chantait avec nous fait
dire que c'est génial et ça fonctionne
c'est à venir benjamin castaldi a animé
des émissions à tient en onomatopées
c'est vrai il faisait occupe ensuite oui
mais oui mais heureusement les bonnes
questions bébé qu'elle est dans cet
album à venir a fait une reprise de
mylène farmer
de quel titre s'agissait-il c'était dans
le titre du premier album des amis et
moi en 2011 c'était quoi déshabillez moi
déshabillez moi de mylène farmer mais
non c'est pas moi
moi j'écoute ses dépenses à votre façon
cinq autres nations ouais rencontre
tation enfin ses valises et aussi ses
des régions aussi sa coupe et proposer
quelque chose peut-être nous a conté toi
il y aura rien adrien bref je peux aller
rien répond c'est aléatoire estime
qu'elle a répondu je suis libertine
non je suis une carte ans mais non je
veux des réponses alors il absolument
dire la phrase je chantais
soit là
[Musique]
jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien
mais
à
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mettez moi pas la route
j'aime ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
jamais
je suis
[Applaudissements]
non
je voulais je suis alors dit je suis en
clientèle et rectifier une petite chose
c'était pas un titre de mon album
d'accord c'était avant mon album est la
célèbre dj qui s'appelle offer nissim
qu'il a sorti ce morceau spécialement
pour la gay pride de tel-aviv en 2013
qui est un des meilleurs gay pride du
monde et je tiens à leur dire parce
qu'il ya deux jours elle a eu lieu et
encore une fois des gens sont venus du
monde entier ils se sont éclatés parce
que c'est un pays très ouvert et qu'il
la 1000ème les gens tels qu'ils sont et
avec leurs différences donc je suis très
fier de porter ce titre qui ont le moins
vrai message cette reprise
[Applaudissements]